Hi everybody. Welcome back. Um
we are going to be talking about as
you've seen whether your ambitions are
godly or not. We've had some questions
before with people who have written into
us and some young people are wondering.
I know life is crazy right now, but God
still wants you to use your time wisely
and
do what praises and glorifies him. So
without further ado, I hope things are
going well for you guys, but we're just
going to get straight into this. So my
first question to you is, have you ever
realized that when someone is truly in
it for Christ that they aren't worried
about money?
This does in fact happen to be the
truth. You're not fixated on how to make
it. You're actually focused on him.
And somehow everything you need and more
usually starts falling into place during
this time.
You usually find your spouse that God
had for you, your career or job that you
were meant to have.
So God tells us already based on this
Matthew 6:33,
"But seek ye first the kingdom of God
and his righteousness, and all these
things shall be added unto you."
You know, that's not just a feelgood
verse. It's actually how things work.
It's kind of the law of nature with God.
The world chases the blessings while
believers
chase the blesser. At least that's what
should be happening.
But let me show you as we get into this
right how this looks in the Bible. We
look at Joseph. He never pursued status
or money.
He didn't campaign for power or buy his
way into Pharaoh's courts.
He was faithful as a slave, in prison,
as a shepherd boy with his family and in
obscurity or poverty.
And when Pharaoh called upon him to
answer about the dream, he said, "It is
not in me. God shall give Pharaoh an
answer of peace. So do not look at me.
My God will answer you." He gave all the
glory to God and that is exactly why God
could raise him up
because he wasn't trying to raise
himself. That's important part to know
about yourself when you are going
towards
different dreams and goals.
We also want to look at Abraham when
we're talking about this. He was very
wealthy. In fact, he had herds, cattle,
um huge groups of people, maid servants,
manervants. He traveled with so many
tents and people that followed him that
they were a huge number that even the
Egyptian Pharaoh was worried about and
many more.
But he wasn't ruled by his riches. He's
a very good example.
When there was strife between his
herdsmen and lots,
Abraham didn't demand the better pasture
land. He said instead, "If you will take
the left hand, then I will go to the
right." In Genesis 13:9,
and if you go
to the right, I will go to the left.
And also when he encountered the king of
Sodom, which offered him riches after
the battle, he said,"I will not take
from you a thread even to a shoe latchet
or a shoelace,
lest you should say, I have made Abraham
rich
because he didn't want to give any
credence to other people thinking that
because of them he got rich or because
of
opportunities he was given. He wanted
not even to stroke his own ego and get
it thinking like, "Oh yeah, I'm so
great. I did this." You know, he wanted
to give all the glory back to God as
well and keep his mind in check.
Because God had told him, "I am your
shield and your exceedingly great
reward."
That's in Genesis 15 verse one.
And when he said he was talking about I
won't even take a shoe latchet, that was
in Genesis 14 23.
And then there's Jacob.
Jacob
can be like a lot of us trying to find
our way in the world. What are we going
to do? How are we going to go about
getting it? And he's an example of how
not to do it. He tried to take what God
was always willing to give.
He schemed. He lied and pretended and
even wore skins to deceive skins to
deceive his own father.
But it wasn't until he wrestled with
God, meaning that he was he had become
broken by God and stopped trying to make
it happen for himself
that
it worked. It was not in his own power
and everything changed.
It says in Genesis 32:28,
"Thy name, says God to Jacob, thy name
shall be called no more Jacob, but
Israel. For as a prince hast thou power
with God and with men, and have
prevailed."
Jacob didn't prevail through striving.
He actually prevailed through
surrender.
I know it sounds kind of funny, but he
was ready to go, Lord, what do you have
for me? I will fight you until you bless
me. Until you come for me and tell me
what I'm supposed to do. And then when
it finally stopped, he surrendered to it
as well.
You see, when God is your first,
you don't have to force anything.
You don't have to sell your soul, climb
over others, or play dirty.
Many people are looking at influencers,
other YouTubers, big houses, cars,
money,
girls, boys, I don't know. Tons of
people, popularity,
and you know, celebrities, anything you
name it.
They all had to climb over others, sell
their soul, and definitely play dirty.
The Bible has something to say about
money and getting rich. And many people
seem to not realize this, but here's a
verses I found.
It says in Proverbs 23:4,
"Labor not to be rich, cease from thine
own understanding or wisdom." In another
interpretation,
now if we go to Proverbs 28 22, he that
hasteneth to be rich has an evil eye.
those who run after. In other words,
being rich has have an evil eye and
considerth not that poverty shall come
upon him.
Now, this could be a both ways there.
You run after wealth and you spend it
all being frivolous and you end up
becoming poor in the long run. Or in
most cases, it's actually talking about
the state of the heart. you are going to
become poor in spirit and lost.
It also says in 1 Timothy 6 verse 10,
for the love of money is the root of all
evil, which while some covet after, they
have aired from the faith and pierce
themselves through with many sorrows.
You see, usually
climbing the ladder takes so much um
compromise of morals, self-dignity, and
many other things
of family time of being there that
you are piercing yourself through with
many sorrows. You are hurting yourself
and others along with it. It's built
that way in Satan's system. And this
money-making system is indeed not what
God meant it to be. It is Satan's
system.
And so, as we look at these people and
what God has to say about it,
we have to call out a few things.
It's not through a vision board that you
accomplish these things. It's not
through manifesting.
It's not through showing some skin,
which many have to do. um to get to be
an actor or celebrity again, a music
artist. As we've seen, there's been
scandals coming out, diddy parties. We
know this is happening.
It's not through sleeping around. It's
not by listening to vibrations and
frequencies thinking you can attract
wealth and just think happy, positive,
prosperous thoughts.
It's not by entering into some
initiation of secrecy that promises
you'll move up in rank.
If you perform the next ritual
and as long as you pay your dues,
that's not God. It's witchcraft.
And bribes don't count either.
Whether it's Diddy, like I said, or
Hollywood celebrities or Freemasonry or
MLMs that operate like spiritual
pyramids, even some churches, in fact, I
would be wrong if I didn't correct
myself and say most churches today
function this way.
It's an I rub your back, you rub mine
type of thing. Or you support my
platform and I'll give you a platform.
Give to be seen. Give to receive.
No, that's not godly. That's not the way
it should be.
These are Satan's PS of control, his
counterfeit ladder of success.
And every step that you climb,
it's a contract,
a rope around your neck.
Proverbs 21:6 says, "The getting of
treasures by a lying tongue is a vanity
tossed to and fro of them that seek
death."
Basically, you're already on that noose
and you're swinging.
Yes, these satanic methods do work for a
while and as long as you keep the demons
happy, but once you don't do what they
want, they will be the ones after you
and you'll be on their hit list.
But they work to destroy you
little by little, chipping away, like I
said, at your self-dignity, your morals,
your spiritual life, everything,
your family life.
Yeah, it's going to destroy you. See,
these are baited hooks in a slaughter
house
or if you want to call it this, in a
web. And once in Satan's web, he pulls
the strings.
He is in control. And you,
you're in control less and less.
And you may come to find even that you
don't even know who you are anymore.
And no, it's not through partnerships
with pagan organizations because they
have the money though that through their
debaucherous ways, but can give you your
outlet to show your movies to go ahead
and be an an actor or
to even have a hospital
with them. You see, these are
organizations that
we are not supposed to be in
partnership with at all.
They will come back to bite you.
And by the way,
if it's by tweaking the truth and making
it easier for people to hear,
no, it's not godly either. If you're
softening the word so that you do not
offend
or changing your message
just to keep the donors happy.
Hello pastors,
ministries and churches.
Check yourselves, please.
Because I know personally that several
are not operating in the up and up.
They tickle ears. They practice their
messages to only give the people what
they want to hear.
So, I'm here to tell you along with what
I'm saying that if you only preach what
people want to hear and if you refuse to
say what's biblically sound because it
might cost you something,
that's not truth. That's full
compromise.
And compromise never leads to God's
kingdom.
No sugar coating or beating around the
bush either.
And if deep down
if you know that you took a position of
authority to be seen, to be heard, to
cover a vice or a double life in the
background
or to gain status,
to rub shoulders with the wealthy in
crowd.
Man, it's time to realize Judas is
looking you in the mirror.
He is alive.
He is the same demon of greed that is
alive in you.
And his power-hungry appetite
will be your demise if not gotten rid of
now.
There are always consequences to
following that demon of greed. Let me
tell you,
you see, in my own life,
I had a little bit of experience with
some of this.
I grew up in a very
affluent community. I grew up with
wealthy people, millionaires, rising
millionaires around me. I saw it happen
within a couple years to them.
And without getting into it,
there's probably one one that I know of
that was actually
did it God's way, was handed the money
just like Abraham was. All the rest
compromised.
They exploited others
and they did not play fairly to get
where they are.
So, as a kid,
as we all do, but even as a at a small
age, you're asked, "What are you going
to be when you grow up?"
And it goes into your high school years,
your college years. It's okay. We all
need to think about this, but you know,
I didn't exactly know what to do. Part
of you
sees what the world has to offer, and
you go, "What do I do? Do I go after
money? Do I go after fame? Do I choose
something that will definitely secure me
for life, to be in a good spot
financially?
I definitely was seeing that. I I saw
some people go into business solely to
make money,
to kind of play games with people, to
get money and live in a big house and
have the cars and, you know, all that
too.
And so I just decided to go with what I
was passionate about. And God gave me
that passion. I went for my first degree
in college for that. And I loved it. But
when I came out, I found out like most
of us when God gives you a passion, he
doesn't make it very easy
all the time.
It didn't make much money. And that's
okay. I learned that it was not actually
what he wanted me to do as a job.
not permanently, but it was something he
wanted me to keep in my life to bless
others on the side. And you will learn
those things as you go. So, I had office
jobs. I worked for CEOs, executive
managers, everything.
I was secretary for a long time. Um, did
a great job. You know, that kind of
keeps you stuck as well and doesn't pay
that well a lot of the time, too. And so
I was finding I wasn't fulfilled,
especially not spiritually. I wasn't
doing anything that really gave me
happiness.
Even though I was good at organization
and filing and so on, I could handle the
back end of most people's businesses
because I was working for the CEO or
whatever.
But
I found that
there was a bit of something that
happened in college as well. It wasn't
just that I went for my degree and I
realized I didn't make money during the
time period. If you haven't heard a
little bit of my testimony, this is
where it starts coming in.
I was always good at school. I love
school actually.
And
because of that, I was a little
bookworm. And in college, I was even
known as one a little bit. And it was it
was acceptable. But I'd never known what
popularity felt like. And in my junior
year, I decided
I was going to be popular.
And I'd always been good at dancing any
kind.
And I had this draw
towards hip-hop music. So I became a
hip-hop dancer in college while keeping
up my studies and becoming very popular
mingling at parties. Although I didn't
do the drugs, drinking or sleeping
around, I was just there to mingle and
be kind of the it girl.
And um
I did it, but it was so empty. I want
people to understand this. It was so
empty trying to keep up appearances.
Imagine spending two hours on your hair
every day
or your makeup together, your hair and
makeup.
That's not normal.
That's
being self-absorbed.
And that was what I was doing.
And I play hip-hop music the whole time
just to give myself a boost of my ego.
So I went out. So when I went out I was
just like, "Yeah, I can do anything. I'm
so great." Like it kind of just gave you
this idea of how great you were and you
could do anything you wanted, even
things that aren't weren't good.
Um,
and so
I don't know why I decided to do that,
but that greed, I guess I'm calling it
greed, but even going after fortune,
fame, popularity, I believe, is greed.
And
so if I skip, all of a sudden, I got out
of that. I I came out of that phase and
recovered from it um in my last senior
year of college.
And then as time went on um
I should say even within the last five
years, I had something terrible happen
in my life and I had to start from the
ground up to put my life back together.
And so I decided I was going to go for a
second degree.
And I am ashamed to say that from
experience of this, I chose
solely based on how much money it would
make me
my second degree program. And I did. I
went for it. I did great.
I graduated and I applied for jobs. And
I have the proof.
I applied for more than 300 jobs on
LinkedIn when I graduated.
And this is at a time I was single
again. Like I said, my life I had just
had to recover from a bunch of stuff
that happened to me. It was a very
challenging time of life. I was finally
ready. And I got this invitation
suddenly from Mikey
to come to Little Light and do a
presentation.
So I thought, well, I'm not hearing back
from any of these jobs. maybe I'll go.
And
you know, I heard they were laying off
people in that line of work anyway.
And so I just thought, well, I have to
wait it out. That's what everyone told
me. You just to wait it out and they
will be hiring again.
This is my cyber security degree, by the
way. And
nobody contacted me. Nobody contacted
me. So I just went I went, "Well, God is
opening this door over here to do the
presentation at Little Light Studios.
I'm going to go, then I'll come back
home. Probably nothing will change.
We'll see what happens.
And I was wrong. In fact, time went on
and time went on.
That by the time I went to do my
presentation at Little Light,
I was at the point that God wanted me to
be at finally.
I had finally let go of trying to make
my own way happen.
And I said, "Okay, Lord, what do you
want me to do? What am I here for? Maybe
this isn't what you have at all. I know
these reasons that I had behind
everything going towards cyber security
wasn't in the right place."
He knew it. And it was kind of justice.
justice because I never did hear back
from anybody about a job. And that
evening at Little Light Studios
presentation went so well they were
offering me a job
and my whole life changed. I didn't know
that God
I knew
that I wanted to be giving presentations
and helping people understand the truths
of the Bible in our world,
but I'd never been given the
opportunity. And so I just thought,
"Yes, I'll take the job." So here I am
moving to a different state, meeting
Mikey for the first time in person,
realizing
pretty immediately that he was to be my
spouse. So God had my spouse waiting for
me.
and
a whole new life ensued which was much
better than I'd ever
really experienced both in a
relationship and a career ever before.
So I realized this is where God wanted
me. And if I had never surrendered
and gotten to this point where I gave up
trying to make it what I wanted, I
wouldn't be here. I would still be
fighting against God.
And um I just I think
all of this
are moments within with college being a
dancer, wanting to be popular, um
trying to find my own way with
my second career and
all of it. I was letting greed or Judas
as I'm calling it
was coming alive in me looking me back
in the mirror
and
we have to learn to let go and trust God
a lot more is what I realized
because again as I realized from growing
up years and meeting the people that had
been very wealthy around me
and then God started talking to me about
it.
Maybe it's foresight,
I'm sorry, hindsight about it all now.
But no one who climbs the ladder of
lies, I found out no one who uses deceit
or sorcery or rituals or witchcraft will
be in heaven.
Let me tell you guys, that includes
people,
sorry, that includes people who are
using
a career to just make money and swindle
people also where they're not doing it
fairly or honestly.
I've seen a lot of that, too.
So, it's time to re-evaluate your life.
It's time to recognize
the Judas within you
and crucify your filthy ways.
I don't say this to be rude, but I know
we all need to be honest with ourselves
and become clean.
See, time is short and
it's coming closer and closer to being
the time
which God spoke about. In fact, I'll be
candid as we are here.
We are seeing right now the brink of the
counter revival
for the start of the national Sunday law
that will begin the new world order.
We are here.
So I beg of you to get your stuff
together.
Repent. Surrender.
Seek him.
and clean up your life
because he cares
and we've got to be using our hands, our
efforts, our time, and our minds wisely.
Please consider this your warning.
Thank you guys for being here. Have a
good night.